Youtube will announce will remove all pop-up annotations on January 15th. Oh-ho-ho
Kids will never know the true joy.
They will never understand how much happiness the annotations gave.
They will never see this. (Annotation spam)
They will never understand.
(More annotation spam)
This MAKES ME SO FREAKING angry.
I could just d- *glass breaking*
*explosions*
Someone needs to pay for this. We need to hold men ACCOUNTABLE.
This is something new I've learned.
Sasuke--That's right--Sasuke is the one that will pay the price for this.
What started off as a cute little photo of two brothers
just hanging out has now turned into pain for Sasuke.
Sasuke needs to PAY
Sasuke, you better freakin subscribe to pewdiepie
said Mr Beast.
You're weak Sasuke you lack
SAUCE sauce-ke
damn even ninja hit sasuke. Damn
I think it's safe to say that uh no one likes sasuke that edgy little (bleep) sorry.
Jesus Christ I think it's safe to say
that no one likes sasuke. He does have sauce in his name though
so he can't be that bad.
Marge Simpson..MARGE SIMPSON. STOP it. You're killing him!!
You're killing sasuke! you're weak sasuke you lack sauce.
That's what you were gonna say you dumb ass Shaggy from Scooby Doo.
God damn what a savage. Oh my God it's that girl
from that anime where they play drums and guitar.
I forgot the name. Why is everyone fighting Sasuke. Oh
wait I said it already. There is of course also that
sitting on Sasuke. This is what you get for killing
the Naruto village. The ninja village. I don't remember what the plot
was. Maybe oh it was his brother that did it. Well this is what you get, Sasuke
for not being good friends to Naruto. There is of course
the ultimate crossover of this. Someone has to do it. You know it always happens.
This is not a new meme. Okay kids I've been around long enough to know that this is not the first time this
meme has made a thing. Sasuke to show you the power of flex tape.
I sawed your village in half. Damn
flex tape just put the village together with tape
Brad even Brad this again Sasuke I can't
believe it. Brad. How could you do this.
Brad would never do this. Brad WOULD NEVER DO THIS. You will
never get G fuel sponsorship 30 percent off Enter the code pewdiepie
Brad. Don't make me laugh.
Ahh. Subscribe to PewDiePie
or sasuke dies. Listen here kids I'm desperate.
I will kill Sasuke. I will do i- I will do it like I'm serious.
I'm not joking around here. I will.
*war face*
That was my war face. If you're not intimidated by that then I
guess you're a tough pal
Now everyone just has to take it too far. Everyone just
Has to do the one that no one wanted to see version of this.
Okay all right. Okay I get it
okay. All right. Okay. God damn it. I'm sorry Sasuke,
But that's how mafia works and everybody knows that.
Why is Shaggy from Scooby Doo such a god damn savage?
Why do I look identical like him?
He's rocking the white hair like I used to have when my power level was stronger.
Okay. It's time to stop. It's definitely time to stop. This meme get a 4 out of 5.
And you know why? You know why. You really want to know why?
'cuz sasuke killed the annotations on YouTube.
Naruto would never do this. next *clap* meme *clap*.
What's that? Oh sorry I can't- I can't hear you. I got my air
pods. Sorry. What were you saying nandesuka motoyukuri kudasai
Excuse me? What did you say? Have you noticed I have air pods?
Why does everyone have air pods guys like what the freak is
happening here. Everyone has air pods like Ugandan knuckles
have airpods thats how you know maybe there's something suspicious going on here.
Even frickin chickens have airpods and waves.
How can everyone afford these. They're like super expensive. I don't. I
just like I don't like-I just like-I don't like-Just like I don't get it.
Mark Zuckerberg has it. Well now you know it's
Normie
Wave check.
Hey guys I uh i've been wearing this hat this whole episode so I think it's
time for me to reveal my waves. Oh
that's right. Cultural appropriation. Oh my God
I am so sorry guys. That was way out of line. This time,
If I get called out I will take a hundred percent response.
Oh hey Mr. Air Pod, you're standing in the middle of the road.
Be careful. There might be a-oh no there's a man
move Mr. Air Pod, move! Oh no he's got cars
in. He can't hear me. Oh no.
You guys get it? Because it's the opposite of the meme AHAHAHA
is this meme version of pyrocynical
Aw dude it's Keemstar. Don't tell me keemstar got waves.
Don't freakin tell me.
Oh damn. Those are some waves dawg damnnn damnnnn
YuhhHuhhHuuhH. Respect keemtar like
even Stalin had waves. I think it's okay for white people to have waves
because Stalin had waves for everyone saying that white people can't have waves.
Excuse me. Stalin had waves stop putting waves
on everything. ugh, no. Asian people be like. Oh shit.
Martin Luther King has air--waves and pods
Damn. Oh shoot.
eh What's his name? President Donald Trump. The waves. This
is so racism shaking my head right now. Obama has waves.
Dude I thought he was dead. My foreskin the air pod I'm stealing.
Best Buy employees. So that's how everyone gets air pods.
Ok. all right. Do a wave check thanos. Dont do wave
Check. It's dangerous
Let's see those waves thanos. God damn that's hot.
Yuhhh. So that's how Thanos gets his power.
All right let's check out the waves. Check out the waves.
WOAHHHHHHH
That's some actual waves! yuhhhhh
the wave airpod meme gets zero. You know why.
Because you can buy these. Why--why have
airpods which you can barely-- I mean they're right in your face. If you
really want to show off your airpods then why don't you get these
instead OK. Virgin Air pods. Chad
Kawaii Sugoi Neko Chan razer PewDiePie edition headphones
Are you gonna be a virgin or a chad. I'm gonna leave that answer up to you because I already know you f-ing Virgin's
next meme
Guys that's what they're trading. trade what?all those videos. We have to do something.
and we have to do it now.
who's that?
This is the worst meme of all time but I still love it so much.
Why is--haha
This hamster is my last Braincell
like
Who filmed this and why.
Why does--hahahha
My current mood right now.
Oh yeah.
It's so cute and horrible looking
Meme are just getting worse every year. Show them hamster meme
What the freak duuuuude
Same energy. Next up we have the-- another
arm related meme. Isn't that crazy two of them one week
like what the hell was up with arms lately. Okay so it's the one from
Spider verse where he put the arms on this girl
And I think the problem with this meme is that it's just not funny.
Guys explain to me what's funny about this.
Jesus christ I don't get this man. It only works as a crossover.
that meme was so bad.
Set me down at least six thousand years. Humanity will never recover.
I'm tired of this. You know we were looking so promising this year.
Big chungus. That's how mafia works.
So many epic memes. But now
The system has gone too far and I'm so freaking
tired of pretending to be okay with it.
And why do I still do this fake swedish accent. it was never funny.
BONUS MEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEME!!!!!
We have time for bonus meme everybody.
Holy freaking moley gorgom(?)
Soley(?). Jesus blesses this video himself
meme review has two bonus memes in a row holy heck.
Okay we're gonna have to pull out something really nice.
Something really very epic. He will never have a girlfriend.
I don't know if you guys have seen this meme but this is-
look it's super mario. He will never have a girlfriend
and it's like pfffffttt-- its shia lebouf
And then it's like pfffff dude I bet there's a pewdiepie version of it where I
look like super ugly and then it's like Damn.
She
will never become Marge Simpson.
Oh pffffffff what that freak dude.
So how do you want a gay kiss. OK.
The gilette commercial had action everywhere. Finally something positive
is happening in the meme community. You will never be balling. That's what
we would say in 2018 but in 2019
we's be balling
Look at that. Stop hating. He will never become Bart
Simpson, they said. Point proven you actual liberal
meh! she's just a male OP fantasy without  personality. Girl's need
A more realistic character to identify i--what
the fuhhh what the fuh dude shoe(?)
wah-ah-uh She is so frickin cute.
Everyone watching Harry Potter. Oh God. oosh, oosh
Scooby Doo. He will never be balling.
Damn son he's be balling fat dunks and stuff.
Okay
this has been meme review.
I hope you guys enjoyed this episode. We're trying out something new here so I
hope you guys support this series by smashing like and subscribing. Now I don't
know if you guys heard about this but this website called T-series.
It looks like they're gonna take over my channel pretty soon like I'm
not like paying attention to that kind of stuff.
But if you like want to subscribe so that we can beat them.
I think that would be pretty cool. Just to like show the power of the army of meme
reviewsters my fellow memers. So yeah I don't know.
Like just subscribe or whatever. I don't really--It doesn't like matter